Hi, I'm Sarah Grafman,
I'm here from HarvardX.
I'm Sejal Vashi, I'm here
from the the Harvard TH Sam
School of Public Health.
And we have some
guests who would
like to introduce themselves.
We're just-- microphones
for recording.
Yeah, we're just as
loud without them.
Randy King, I'm a
professor of cell biology
at the medical
school, and do a lot
of teaching in the first
year curriculum over there.
I'm Peter Boy, I
teach Chinese history
in the department of East
Asian language and civilization
in the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences.
Thank you both for agreeing
to participate in this today,
and thank you all
for coming today.
So as you know, we're here to
talk about failure and success.
I'm glad we're recording
this for posterity's sake,
though also I'm aware
that talking about failure
can be an uncomfortable thing.
So please know that what's
talked about in here,
we're not going to go
off into the hallways
and talk about everybody, "oh
can you believe he did that?"
It's going to stay in this room.
And so we wanted to start
this by acknowledging,
mostly we talk about failure
in an educational context,
we usually talk about
student failure.
What does failure mean when
you think about the students
that some of you teach?
Feel free to just shout
out or raise your hands.
When a student is
failing, what do you do?
Harvard students don't fail.
[LAUGHTER]
Okay then.
Average grade is an A minus.
They can't fail.
I did see some hands this
morning when asked people give,
I think it was D's.
Has anyone here encountered
a student that is possibly
failing, approaching failure?
Folks, just want to--
please share.
Well I teach Spanish
language classes,
[INAUDIBLE] the
closest to failure
is when you see a student
stop attending class,
because we teach all
in section, we're
acutely aware of our numbers.
There's failure when
they just stop showing up
and stop even trying,
what about failure--
That's not necessarily
the same thing.
Tell me more, please.
Sometimes there are
extenuating circumstances,
personal circumstances
that have nothing
to do with the
student's motivation.
Any other tales of -- yes?
We have, at the medical
school, students every year
who fail in objective
structured clinical exam
of their clinical skills.
And then, you know, have to
assign some sort of remediation
if they actually haven't
been able to demonstrate
that they've learned core
things that every graduating med
student is supposed to know.
And every year we have
a handful of them.
Certain, sort of,
educational cultures,
there are more opportunities
where you're going to fail.
Others, life circumstances
might take you out of it.
Sometimes failure sort of
means that you're challenged,
you're trying, you're just
not quite getting there.
Do you think that's what you
think about when you think
about failing successfully?
When a student is
trying to do something
they haven't done before,
and they don't quite
know the steps to do it?
Does anyone have any
examples of that?
Whether it's in a current class
or in the past or maybe even
your own experience
as a student.
Well, [INAUDIBLE] training for
staff and alumni development
But I also teach in
the extension school
and in the strategic
management program,
and we have students
who come from a variety
of different
backgrounds, many of whom
haven't been in school in
a long time, many of whom
have incredibly
successful careers
but are now coming
back for a degree,
and I have had students who
were very successful in one area
are now coming to the
management program
because they've achieved
a degree of success
in a functional
area or as managers,
and sometimes they don't have
a finance background, finance
skills.
And they take this
class [INAUDIBLE]
strategic management.
And they have sort
of the prerequisites
that they took many years
ago, but they're really not
up to speed in those skills.
In those skills.
And they're very committed and
dedicated and they do struggle.
And it's exactly what you
described, they're motivated
and they're invested,
but they just don't it's
something out of
their comfort zone.
And so they have to put in a
lot of effort as to why to help.
Thank you for that story.
Yes, please.
Well, I'm going to out
myself as a student.
I recently took an extension
school class where I got great
grades, like an A+
average for the class.
When I tried to apply those
skills outside of the class,
just nothing.
Could not, like I knew how
to answer all the questions,
I could not apply
it outside of class.
That was probably
for a lot of reasons.
It's one other kind of
failure, where you look
successful but in the end--
Thank you, that's actually
a great transition,
because while I think as
folks who work as educators,
you sort of sometimes do
encounter students who
are struggling and who
are potentially failing,
but actually our
focus today is going
to be a lot more on
how we take risks
and the opportunities
for failure and success
that come with that.
And with that I'm
going to hand it over
to Sejal who's going to give
everyone a chance to fail.
So in light of
failure, I'm going
to tell you guys about
my personal failure
a few years ago.
My freshman year of
college, my roommates
decided that A's and
F's go on the fridge.
The first and only F was
mine, and it stayed up there
for a very long time.
But again, it was
this environment
where we got to fail, and they
were excited to support me
in my failure.
I still remember it was an
ecology, evolution and bio
class.
So now I'm hoping that
you guys fail with me.
I'm asking for five
to six volunteers,
it is going to require kneeling.
If you can join us in
the back of the room
that would be great.
If you've done a helium
stick exercise, please
do not volunteer.
So question for those of
you who decided to do this,
why were you willing
to take the risk?
To help you out to
a certain extent.
It's uncomfortable to
be in front of people
and be waiting,
waiting, waiting.
And I learned from
my colleague, you
don't have to tell your
right from your left, which
I fail at.
Thanks, anyone else
who agreed to do this?
For those of you who didn't
want to take the risk,
why didn't you want
to take the risk?
Kneeling.
[LAUGHTER] That's why I wanted
to tell you ahead of time
it does require kneeling.
So, first thing,
willing to take a risk,
this is an environment
where at least five of you
felt comfortable
taking the risk.
For those of you that
didn't, and for those of you
that were watching,
what do you think would
have helped them not fail?
More instruction?
More instruction.
Going slowly.
And practice.
Practice.
Communicating
amongst themselves.
Communicating.
Less constraints.
Sorry?
Preparation.
And I know there
are some people who
had done this
exercise, because when
I was like if you've
done it before,
you can't be a volunteer.
What if they had been able
to tell you some tips on what
to do and what to expect?
So it's going to be our second
take away for today, is support
and where to get it.
And then, finally,
those of you that did
do it, what did you
learn right away?
Or even if you just saw them.
More instruction helpful.
More instruction helpful,
what did the stick
do that you weren't expecting?
You said it.
It went faster.
It went way faster than
you'd think it would go.
So now knowing that, do you
think you could pass it?
If you were given a
couple more tries?
Maybe.
So, yeah?
I guess I was
interested, why didn't we
stop and talk to one another?
Like it was sort of interesting,
we weren't specifically told
that we couldn't talk to one
another, we were all out there,
we were given a task it
was clearly a joint task,
yet we chose to do
it as individuals,
and if we had just
stopped for a minute
and actually spoken
to one another
I think we probably could
have done it successfully.
So the circumstance
was that the teacher
was there watching
you and overlooking,
so that, in some sense,
your relationship was not
to each other, but was to
the teacher who was present.
And so, if she had walked
away and stood up here,
and turned her back
to you, would you
have talked to each other?
There's still a barrier, right?
Like I have this kind of
automatic relationship with you
all, because you're telling
me about the exercise,
even if you're not telling
me about the exercise.
But I don't know my colleagues.
And just that small fact can
prevent some simple sharing.
So in a sense, you're
doing the same activity
but working in a silo.
I was just curious,
you said helium stick
and I wanted to say, why is
it called a helium stick,
now I know why.
It's lighter than you
would think it would be.
But if you had even just
paused and basically said,
take one minute
before you start,
that would have created the
same kind of uncomfortableness
that would have led
the conversation.
So normally this exercise
is used to teach leadership
and eventually as
the more you do it,
someone is going to come
about and be a leader, start
communicating, but
I actually like
it better as an
exercise of failure
and how to learn from that.
So again, we're going to
go through these three
takeaways towards
the end as well,
but basically, take the risk.
What's going to make
you take the risk?
Get support, and what
are you learning from it.
So with that,
we're going to have
you guys turn into your tables.
So please just introduce
yourself to everyone
at the table, we're
going to a couple
of things in our small groups.
Introduce yourself to
the people at the table
and just take a
moment to discuss
a recent failure you
might be willing to share
with the group.
You shared your A's
and F on the fringe.
Just this morning I
opened the refrigerator
and found that the bread I'm
making for Rosh Hashana tonight
had overflowed from the bowl
I'd put it in last night.
So I had to do some
quick fixing of that,
and we'll see what it's like
when I come home later today.
So, just take a moment, turn
and introduce yourselves,
and just talk about a recent
failure you feel comfortable
chatting about.
Just take about five
minutes for this.
Thank you all for
sharing your stories,
I feel like I
heard some pretty--
from silly to heavy things.
So thank you all
for contributing.
Peter's now going to share with
everyone a story about taking
risks in his teaching.
So this is a story
that I realized
only today was supposed
to end with success,
but I'm going to talk
about abysmal failure.
And I'll take around five to ten
minutes to tell you the story.
So, I've been teaching
with a colleague a course--
sort of a general introduction
to Chinese history
from antiquity from the
Neolithic into the present,
for around well, over
25 years I think.
And turned out, I studied
abroad so I had never
been in a lecture
course, so I had no idea
what a lecture course was
and so I had to do it myself.
It turned out I was
a very good lecturer.
Surprised me,
surprised everyone.
Yeah it really surprised
everyone else in my department.
So we went along, and
at a certain moment
we thought, back
in the early 90s,
what you could do
with a website.
We thought about ways in
which we could use the web
to give students different
ways, interactive ways,
of engaging with history and
seeing things for themselves.
To make points that
we wanted to make.
The central point
we wanted to make
was that China was not
a unit of analysis,
except at the political level.
That thinking about it as a
single culture was mistaken,
thinking about all peoples being
the same, thinking about them
all being, as an email from
one of the students in our DCE
course said, worker bees and
ants who have no individuality.
And we tried to break down
assumptions like that.
So, from there, having
worked on the website
with people who
are just beginning
to do that at Harvard, and then
DCE said you could take an FAS
course and you could put it
online as well, so that's cool,
let's do that.
Because we found what
when we had the website,
we actually had more
students outside of Harvard
than inside of Harvard,
and they were more
engaged actually
with the website
than Harvard students were.
Because Harvard students
were very motivated,
said tell me what
the assignment is I
will go and do exactly that,
and no more very often.
So we got to the
DCE course and there
are ways of doing that,
they'd film us then
we'd have online
sections with the TF,
but in the course of
that, the TFs were
sort of interested
in what you could
do with digital
stuff, kept saying,
there's so much more we
could do, we should be doing.
And, being somewhat lazy, my
colleague and I didn't do it.
But then we heard about
this HarvardX thing
that was beginning.
And we said, I happen to
be chair of a committee
where I was sitting
next to a person who
had a lot of authority
over HarvardX,
and I said, you know, if you
would let us take our China
course, our Chinese
history course,
and do it as an online course,
if you devote the resource
to that, we'll devote the time.
Because this will be
a chance, actually,
to realize the
promise of this course
that we could do so
much more digitally
online and really do right
by our online students.
That was the idea behind it.
And so we began, and
I actually offered
a new undergraduate
course in, how
do we turn Chinese
history into a MOOC,
and it was right at the
beginning of HarvardX
we had no guidance,
no constraints, very
little support, and
so we just went wild.
The course last
18 months, right?
It has 50 modules, had to be
divided into 10 mini courses,
but we have 500,000
people registering for it.
In fact, as far as I can
tell from the figures I
got the other day,
we've had more students
in that course, and more
people completing it,
than any course except CS-50.
So, that was a real success.
So we said, well,
what we're going
to do is we actually want this
to have real value at Harvard,
and we're going to
take this course
flip the classroom
and what that means is, we have
our lectures have been done
and the HarvardX style is what's
called a chunk and test style.
You know, people's attention
wanders after five or six
minutes you've got
to tell a joke,
and then you put an assessment,
you say, are you awake still?
You'll push this button or
multiple choice question,
or write a sentence or two.
And so we said, we'll do
that with our students.
We'll take our lectures,
and we'll put them on--
they'll just use NX platform,
the HarvardX platform,
they'll do that and then when
they come to class, rather
than us lecturing for
three hours a week
with a fourth hour
of section, we
will use that class time to
engage with the students.
The students always
say they want
to engage with the
professors, we're
going to engage with the
students, really intensively.
We'll have
discussion, we'll have
things to read and
discuss, my colleague
had some cool HBS
cases to bring in,
and he wouldn't have to
lecture anymore, because he
was a boring lecturer.
When he lectured,
50% of the students
would disappear within a week.
So we went ahead with that.
Now, we didn't quite understand
that if-- but of course,
since we wanted students
to get the lecture
we required them
to do it, and we
said you have to do it
before you come to class,
and sometimes that meant two
or three hours of modules
before you came to class.
And you had to do
the assessments,
and we knew because if you
didn't do the assessments,
that was 20% of your grade.
And failure to do that on time
put you in a lot of jeopardy.
So we just thought
this was great,
we were going to spend our
time with our students,
we said to our TFs, "You
guys still get paid,
but we're not going
to have sections,
because we are teaching the
students the section ourselves.
The professors are going to
be doing all the teaching."
So this is a class that had
student ratings in the Q Guide,
like 4.4, things
like that, where
I had these fantastic ratings
in the Q guide for my lecturing.
I think I got, after
the end of this, 2.6.
In the Q Guide world, this is
like really, really dismal,
going downhill.
And the students really
disliked the course.
And we saw an immediate
drop in enrollment of 50%.
And my friend, my colleague,
who offered some HBS cases
and taught them
in the HBS style,
he did extremely well with that.
So our relationship reversed.
For 20 years he had to
get scores behind me,
he's a very competitive guy.
And now all of a sudden he had
to look at me and the staff
management, "It's all right,
you know, you'll get over this."
And so that was just--
why did it happen?
So that's the first question we
asked, so what happened here?
Because we thought we
were doing a good thing.
Well, we discovered
a couple things.
One is, the graduate
students were unhappy,
because they were being
deprived of a chance
to interact with students
and be teachers themselves.
The students were unhappy,
because they actually
appreciate talking
to graduate students
more than the professors.
That's sort of the culture
they've been brought up
in here at the college.
They were unhappy
because we cold called.
We explained the logic
behind cold calling,
but they were unhappy with that.
And then the other
thing we found
was that of course they
did the assessments,
but that meant that they
had to keep going back
over the online lecture to make
sure they got the answer right.
And to get the answer right,
they had to spend more time.
All of a sudden, their time
on task outside of the class
doubled.
They were unhappy.
And they let us know
they were unhappy,
and students make a
choice, and they walked.
So that was bad for the
study of Chinese history.
If part of your goal
is to get students
to know about Chinese history
and to think analytically
about it, that was bad.
It was bad for us
because it hurt our egos,
and you can make all
sorts of justifications,
the students do need
to do more work,
but they can choose not to.
It wasn't a required course.
We know from some
flipped courses
that are required courses that
they're really successful.
In terms of learning outcomes,
often the students liked them.
But this was an elective,
it wasn't a required course.
So that's a story
of abysmal failure.
And we made some adjustments,
we put back in sections.
But still, I can't say that--
things have not been good.
They would much prefer
to have a lecture,
and I'm very good
at giving lectures.
Right?
So, we're not going to continue
the course and the new Gen Ed
program, it doesn't really fit
the Gen Ed standards anyway.
It's a terrible way
to end your career,
to think that a course--
[LAUGHTER]
That you've just failed.
So you want success out of this.
How do we measure success?
Well, one way that we didn't
talk about enough this morning
is, surely a measure of success
has to be what students learn.
Not whether they like us.
Do students learn more
when they go through this?
Yes.
Do they have to do more
work to learn more?
Yes.
So there is an
comment right here
where you say if I do
more time I'll do better,
but I don't want
to do more time.
I have my notion of what a core
curriculum course, a Gen Ed
course should be, how
many hours it should cost,
and you changed the rules on me.
So those students who
were on the first course
have now all graduated,
and this year,
all of a sudden, our
enrollments doubled.
And I said, wow, so how
do we account for this?
Not only did they double,
but the students are active
and they're enthusiastic
and we have this full room
and you know just constant
discussion and cold calling,
no one gets upset by
that, it's just wonderful.
And so we said, you
know what it is?
It's the new generation
of students are used to,
are more accepting of online
stuff, of flipped classrooms,
of hyper blended learning,
that's what it is.
And the guys who
remember what it
used to be like in
the old days are gone.
And so students come in and
they're having a good time
and it's just great.
And so I said that has to be--
I have no evidence that's
the solution of course--
but has to be the solution.
And then, I was talking
to the staff member
who runs the
undergraduate program
and said, no, I'm afraid not.
She said, you know,
they're changing
the requirements for
undergraduates from the old Gen
Ed to the new Gen Ed, and so the
freshman and sophomores don't
have to do it, but the
juniors and seniors
have to fulfill requirements
of the old days.
That explains your
doubling in enrollments.
But what I will
say, I guess this
is my nod in the
direction of success,
is that the engagement
with the students
in that hour and a half
section has been really quite
extraordinary this year.
Better than anything
we've seen before.
But that may just be a
function of having a full room.
So at the moment, I
don't know whether it's
a success or failure yet.
Thank you so much
for sharing that.
And at the least
from your failure
came a successful sharing
with the room right here.
Yeah, if it matters to you.
Yes.
So I'll actually
ask everyone again,
to go back into
your small groups.
And just take a moment
again to reflect,
and I don't know what you talked
about in your small groups
before, if you talked about sort
of more personal little things,
but if you could take a moment
and, thank you again to Peter
for really sharing,
reflect on a failure
in your professional life.
Something that didn't go the
way you thought it would,
and what lessons--
did you just say,
oh that didn't work,
I'm never trying
it again, or what
lessons learned came from that?
And we'll take just
about five or so minutes
to reflect on that.
And also thinking
about maybe some
risks that you
haven't yet taken.
Risks that didn't
work well and risks
that you haven't yet taken.
So, thank you, and just
take a moment to gather.
So you guys probably all
had different stories,
we just wanted to see, what
are some commonalities that
came about from your tables?
So anyone willing to
share out what you guys
noticed about your failures?
Any, kind of, aha moments?
Any common failures
that you tend to have?
Common support that you need?
Any of that sort.
This is not really an
answer to your question.
That's cool.
But we had a question
about, you know,
you said you were a really good
lecturer, what does that mean?
In terms of students learning
if that's a measure of success,
the lecture isn't necessarily
the most effective way
but honestly, I
like a good lecture,
so it seems complicated so
I'm just curious how you--
So when I'm lecturing, I can
tell whether the students
are understanding right away.
I can tell from whether
it's getting across,
whether my explanation
is working or not.
And so I want it to work.
I want them to
understand, right?
And so if they're
not understanding,
I know I've done a bad job.
The second thing is that,
they should be so caught up
in the problem, or whatever
it is you're talking about,
that they can start
to anticipate,
and sometimes
spontaneously a question
is coming out of the audience.
And that engagement with that
story is really important.
And then-- but I shouldn't
take up this time.
Anybody else?
You guys can ask
questions, I don't mind.
I think we were struck by
the lack of commonality
in our discussion.
Other tables also had a
similar lack of commonalities?
I was just-- if I'm
summarizing correctly--
A professor might try a
novel approach and students,
for whatever reason, maybe
fear failure or just fear
of novelty, don't react
well to the faculty's ideas
and approach and
novel situation.
And is that because the scenario
is challenging or is not
well thought out?
Or is it just the students
that are afraid of novelty?
Pose that question to you guys.
Thoughts on--
I was thinking that one of
the things that's coming out
is like there are a lot
of different ways to fail.
[LAUGHTER]
Are there any commonalities
or categories?
It did seem like one is
mismatches of expectations.
And the whole
question of whether we
could reduce failure and
have more success by thinking
about expectation setting
in a more sophisticated way,
whether it's giving instructions
for your very first exercise,
or the fact that the
expectations of those students,
they're thinking it should be
like the old curriculum instead
of the new or whatever.
I don't know if
that's a category.
That's great.
I actually have an reflection.
I teach language,
beginners Spanish,
so the failures are
related to the grammar
and the explanations
and all that.
But I always have this idea of--
How we approach the
failure of the students
because we failed to explain
to them properly what they--
I see that when I grade a quiz,
and say oh no, I did it wrong.
It's my fault.
That's a moment where
you say, how do I do this.
I mean, grammar is easy, I don't
know about all the disciplines,
language is easy to do.
I know, but-- I don't
know what you think.
Reflections on that?
Just, a little bit of
what you're saying--
piggy backing off of
what Peter was saying,
our small table
discussion, I think
a commonalty is the success
part of the failure, right?
And it requires a
vulnerability just
to take a look at, whether
it's Q scores or attendance,
and wonder why, and not
just wondering but actively
go after why, and
to keep digging
until you can get that answer.
You know, whether you are a
faculty member, an instructor,
or an academic
professional, you know,
opening yourself
up for feedback,
I think that's tough to do, but
people care enough to do it.
Thanks.
Final comments?
All right, I'm going to--
oh.
So I just want to sort of
reiterate the comment--
my assumption is that when I
deal with a student who either
thinks that she isn't
getting what's going on,
or seems to me
not to be getting,
those are two
different categories,
my assumption is that's my
problem, not her problem.
And I've got to figure out
where the mismatch how it arose.
I don't always know
exactly what it
means partly that it
actually goes back to your,
everybody gets A
minuses here, you know,
back to the measure of the
students at the Law School
are pretty talented.
And so it probably is the case
that if student isn't getting
something I'm trying to do,
it's on me, not on the student.
So anyway, again, figuring out
how to respond to that problem
is the hard part.
So I think the magic word
for today is mismatch.
We're looking at mismatch
between expectations
amongst faculty and
students, mismatch
between what I
think I'm teaching
and what I think my
students are comprehending,
and then, basically,
to top it all off,
is how comfortable am
I trying to figure out
where that mismatch lies, and
what am I going to do about it?
So with this I'm now going
pass it over to Randy who--
I always have to look
because it's a lot of words
and I always mix them up--
case based
collaborative learning.
Correct.
So they're doing some novel
stuff at the medical school,
so I just want him to
kind of talk about what's
making them take this risk,
what support you've had,
and kind of what
you've learned so far.
So thanks very much.
So I've taught at the medical
school for about 14 years now,
and have been fortunate
to work with a fantastic
group of first year students.
So in the courses
that I've taught
I typically teach very
early in the curriculum,
so they're just transitioning
to medical school and kind
of getting used to
drinking from a fire hose
as the analogy goes.
And so I think we
have an opportunity
to really understand
how students
react to this sort of
change in their learning.
As undergraduates,
you know, students
have the luxury of time.
In medical school, it
goes at a very fast pace.
And so one of the
challenges we face
is really thinking about how do
we keep students engaged sort
of day in and day out
with a curriculum that
is a lot of material
and a lot of content.
And I think that's
one of the things that
drove the curriculum reform
at the medical school,
and sort of switched to
this so-called case based
collaborative learning
which really was, I think,
a nice outgrowth of the
work of many people,
including Rick Schwartzstein
and others at the school,
and really thinking
about, how can we
best engage our learners.
So the story I wanted to
tell is sort of my experience
in this process.
And sort of thinking about
how we might do this, how
we might take on this approach.
In the old course that I
taught, it was a mix of lecture,
so they'd have a couple of
hours of lecture in the morning,
and then a 90 minute small group
discussion in groups of eight.
And one of the
logistic challenges
that we face with a class of
160 is recruiting 22 discussion
leaders.
These are all faculty,
but faculty kind
of across the school.
Getting a uniformity of
experience for that process
was a challenge,
and that was one
of the motivations for thinking
about other types of formats.
So I would say our curriculum
has been running about three
years now, I'd say about
five or six years ago,
and it's amazing how I'm
hearing echoes of what
Peter said in terms of failure.
We decided to give this a try.
Let's try flipping a session.
So again typically what we were
doing is lecturing for students
for a couple of hours
then a day or so later
they'd go and discuss the
material in their small groups.
And we thought, well,
let's flip this around.
You know, we're recording
all these lectures,
half the students aren't
coming to our lectures,
they're watching
the videos anyway,
surely they'll find this
an interesting exercise.
And so what we told
them was, for two
of the sessions in the course,
instead of having lectures
we are going to have them watch
last year's lecture online,
which we made available to them.
And we said, you know, do that
over the weekend, hint hint.
Do that over the
weekend and then come in
on Monday, and
instead of lecturing,
we're going to work through
a series of problems
together as a large group.
And so gave this a
try, came out with what
I thought were some really
interesting questions that
would require them to apply
their knowledge in this format.
And I would say it was
met with a lot of silence.
Trying to get the students
to participate and answer
questions felt to me
like pulling teeth.
So that was the first session.
And then the second session,
I would say about a third
of the class didn't
even show up.
I'm like, what is going on here?
And so we then--
I don't know if Ed
remembers this at all--
but we basically had to have
a class meeting after this
and talk about professionalism
and the importance of showing
up to class, and that got
into a big debate about, well,
you know, I'm a
student I should really
decide what approach for
learning works best for me,
kind of thing.
So it was a disaster.
I mean it really was.
I'm like, what is
this flipped class?
Like, this is a mess.
I mean I just really
didn't know what to make
of it, to be honest with you.
And so I guess the
question is why do we
keep pursuing this approach?
While other faculty
were experimenting
with this method
in different ways,
we ran a pilot
the following year
where we took a group
of about 40 students,
sitting in a room like this,
working through questions
in that format.
That worked much better
with a group of 40.
Really what I recognize
in retrospect,
was really the key
difference was context.
That-- and I think this
is really the message--
that if you're going to take
chances and do experiments,
and if the experiments
fail, you have
to go back and understand
why the experiment failed.
The reason the first
experiment failed
was that these were students
who were used to learning
in a particular way.
That was actually working
pretty well for them.
And then we said
whoa, we're just
going to change up a
couple of these sessions
and see if this
is a better idea.
Think you take something
that ultimately
can work in its own context
but take it out of context,
and try it this way, it
can be a real disaster.
And so I don't think it was
so much about the content
or the format or the
flipping or so forth,
but really about
the larger context.
And, you know, we
now have a curriculum
that's almost exclusively
flipped sessions
for the medical students.
And they do all the prep
work, they work really hard,
they come to the
sessions, they're really
very engaged and motivated.
I think the faculty
are enjoying this,
and so I think we're
confident that this kind
of flipped classroom format
can work for medical students,
but that sure isn't the
conclusion I would have drawn
from our one pilot experiment.
So I have to say
the lesson that I've
learned from this is, pilots
are critical and important
and we learn from them.
But you also have to really
interpret them properly.
And this notion
of context and how
do you experiment in a
course, is a challenge.
I mean, should
course pilots really
be pilots within a course
or of a whole course?
Because maybe you can't
draw very broad conclusions
from doing specific experiments,
because the students have
a certain set of expectations.
So, in any case, that was the
story that I wanted to share.
I think experimentation is good,
failure you can learn from,
but I guess, keep plowing ahead.
So with that, we're
actually going
to ask you guys to
think about a risk
that you haven't taken, but want
to take within the next year.
Ideally we want you
to write it down
if you're even up for it,
verbalize it with a partner.
You know, the whole thing,
if you write it down
you're more willing to do
it, if you tell it to someone
you're even more
willing to do it.
So with that, again,
think about a risk
that you want to take
within the next year.
And figure out a plan
to make that happen.
And we want to help
you make that happen.
So on the little note cards
that you have at your tables,
just write down resources
that you might want
to help you take this risk.
In these packets as well we've
compiled a bunch of resources
as well.
So there is just some
Harvard specific sites,
the top helped Instructional
Moves just came out,
it's really cool.
And then school
specific contacts,
which really is this phenomenal
list compiled by HILT of folks
that you can reach out to
in the specific schools
who can help you
take these risks.
Anywhere from
filming your lectures
to see what works, to trying out
an activity for you, for giving
you kind of mock students
to test something on,
so all of that is
available for you guys.
And then if you are more
interested in flipping
classrooms, too,
there's a new book
that just came out called
Flipped Learning, A Guide
For Higher Education Faculty,
where he talks about how
he failed with flipping.
So if you like this concept
of failing at flipping,
that book in specific tells
you a lot more about it.
So again, just as the
takeaways from today--
The flipping failure.
Take the risk, get
support, and then learn
from what, most likely,
will be an initial failure.
So, you guys just
want to take some time
to verbalize, write down,
and end on that high note.